judith vous êtes donc l'auteur de cette
enquête du figaro magazine
jean michel blanquer a beaucoup de com
où il ya du fond beaucoup de fonds et
beaucoup d'atouts pour réussir qu elle a
tout d'abord le premier d'entre eux il
ne se cache pas derrière son petit doigt
pour redresser le diagnostic des échecs
de l'éducation nationale mine de rien
aucun ministre ni à gauche ni à droite
ne l'avait fait en arrivant rue de
grenelle personne n'avait dit que les
résultats obtenus par les lycéens
français en france est précisément et en
mathématiques choses moins connus
étaient désastreux et en donner
le rang de la france dans l' ocde lui le
dit il a parlé des ravages de la méthode
mixte c'est-à-dire globale au début
syllabique ensuite les profs ont comme
d'habitude répondu mais ça n'existe plus
ça n'a jamais existé
je les rencontre est évidemment pour
cette enquête
il me racontait que étant donné son âge
il a 52 ans ils étaient concernés par
l'arrivée des maths modernes à l'école
et m'a raconté qu'il avait vu ça
arrivait comme à ce qu'est un skieur ou
à l'avalanche arrivé derrière son dos il
sait qu peut absolument rien faire et
que ce rêve à l'engloutir donc première
à tous une grande lucidité sur l'état de
l'école deuxième atout et non des
moindres il a un président de la
république qui s'intéressent à l'école
et son épouse aussi parce que brigitte
lacombe est une ancienne prof elle était
prof à franklin 800 lycées glissé
jésuites qui ne rigole pas ni avec le
sait les savoirs fondamentaux ni avec la
discipline est en soi une grande
convergence de vue c'est d'ailleurs elle
qui a attiré l'attention des vehlmann
macron sur les livres qui avait fait
jean michel blanquer
c'est elle qui est quasiment à l'origine
sinon la nomination du moins de la
rencontre et jean pierre chevènement que
j'ai également rencontré à l'occasion de
cette enquête me disait la chance
d'avoir un président qui s'intéressent à
l'éducation parce que moi quand
mitterrand m'a nommé rappelez vous
c'était après le drame savary avec cette
tentative de faire un grand service de
l'éducation unifiée avec le privé et
public
chevènement me dise mitterrand but de
brouiller vous carte blanche et plus
jamais entendu parler du jeu source